foreign
[Music]
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel today I have a special
guest on the channel welcome to the
Channel introduce yourself to the people
hi my name is Dr Patrick Flynn I am here
in Green Bay Wisconsin in the United
States and um Pearl I'm so excited to be
with you today I love your channel and I
love your show so it's just a honor to
be with you today I'm
seem to know a lot a lot of facts
it's we're going to share some pretty
awesome stuff that I think is going to
blow the crowd away today so I'm excited
to share it okay so what
so are you how familiar are you with you
like red pill content
uh extremely um remember I've been
involved not only in health care but in
politics for 30 years and so they they
they coincide because we're going to
learn today that um as you understand
health and I understand difference
between men and women uh the the
separation and all the thought processes
are are connected so deeply so I'm very
excited to share from a biological
standpoint uh what I've even put in
clinical practice that Seoul fits in
with the red pill content that you're
gonna love it okay so tell me what is
the red he'll get right about the
differences between men and women
well it's quite simple see now remember
coming from a doctorate standpoint if
I'm going to approach a female there's a
certain level of hormone hormones that a
woman has compared to a guy now here's
what happens and and what I've always
been known for and I'll share my
background a little bit and I'll show my
share my story a little bit but here's
what happens the biology of a woman once
again hormones affect a woman and a man
both physically mentally so therefore
the traits that women have uh are
biological for example we know that
testosterone has not only physical
mental traits but the idea is the the
mental traits once again today are
looked at as bad as toxic which for
example testosterone makes a man very
aggressive okay makes them very laser
focused makes them very competitive and
with the exception of World of Sports
that's looked down for in a world of men
but that but that's biology when it
comes to a woman by Nature estrogens are
very connective that's why like I said
men creates Society women create a home
but what they're trying to do now is
straight to home to society and guess
what happens if you took tried to make a
home life into a football team it would
be it wouldn't match up so the idea is
this and and there are cross traits but
the sad part is this and what we're
seeing now today is we're trying to make
traits of both men and women
dramatically different that's that
that's unbiological because uh By Nature
estrogens do certain physical and mental
things women testosterone do certain
physical mental things to them and we're
trying to tell people that's wrong and
I'm going you're just fighting against
your biology and I'm gonna go into great
detail of it I'm going to show you how I
figured this out 24 years ago and why
I've taught this for so many years so
and all this stuff has come out recently
in the last five ten years I might go
and you guys are dramatically leading
people down the wrong path that's going
to affect them both physically and
mentally it's going to lead to a lot of
problems
so let's let's start 24 years ago what
were you in med school what what
happened
okay so let's do this let's start back
even even earlier this week at the full
story okay so my I was a sick child and
I was diagnosed as a juvenile delinquent
and I grew up in a little small town
um in northern Wisconsin we lived in the
country a couple hundred acres it was
great and but when I would go into the
world
um once again I didn't form well to
society because I had psychological
things today they would call like
Asperger's and things of that well what
happened is I didn't realize that as I
was you have Asperger's yes
I would have been diagnosed of it as a
child okay we'll go through someone
asked me if I had that the other day so
there's someone I know that's like
convinced I have that
what does that mean well isn't a bad
thing we'll go into we'll go into the
psychological aspects of this okay so
let's go through it so so then back then
but they diagnosed as a jewel of
delinquent my mom and my dad were
sitting there going you know if it even
said that if he doesn't get help he'll
be in prison someday well what they
didn't realize that there was physical
things going on my body that that
affected me psychologically okay so long
story short as a teenager as a 13 year
old teenager I started to figure this
out and back then the medical field they
didn't drug many kids so everything was
counseling or everything was behavioral
changes but there was internal physical
changes that led to those mental changes
so I started to figure out as a teenager
and I started to change my foods and I
realized that an email logical problem
so then I I graduated high school went
to college and I said listen I'm going
to study nutrition immunology and and I
thought maybe I'm gonna go into uh some
medical field that did it well I I
realized that the natural route actually
actually gave me more answers uh because
if you look at the today it's a it's a
two and a half trillion dollar system of
trying to change people psychologically
pharmaceutically but nobody ever suffers
from a psychological condition because
they have a pharmaceutical deficiency
now I know it's kind of funny saying
that but think about that you know no
one suffers because they lack
psychiatric medication why they have
problems this way so all of a sudden I
started to go I start to really get into
it and I I was I was going through
school when my graduate school I got my
undergraduate degrees and then all of a
sudden I met this woman
um towards the end of my graduate school
my doctorate and all of a sudden get
this
um
I was starting to date her and no joke
on the second day that I met her she
looked at me and she said I think I'm
going to marry you and I looked there I
said you know something I think you're
right and so we started to hang out and
then after about a couple weeks of
dating she actually let me know that uh
she couldn't have kids that she was
infertile so she suffered from
endometriosis she suffered from cystic
acne
ulcerative colitis and cluster headaches
and she was seeing both medical and
natural people and continue to get
sicker and this time I'm 24 years old
and she's 23. well and find out and put
a few but Pearl if you looked at her
you'd have never even thought anything
was wrong she petite cute blonde
everything like that well then I I
started to look at and go oh my goodness
and knowing being a doctor and I'm not
fully graduated I had about three months
left of school I actually looked at her
and said can I see your laps because
it's some hormonal issue and that's when
I realized that once again that what the
doctors were doing was dramatically
incomplete for example Pearl and I'm
going to ask you a question so walk me
through this and the the this is going
to blow your audience away if we look at
just hormones in general as a male what
is the major dominant hormone that makes
me who I am as a male just in general is
it testosterone
100 right 100 right okay now as a woman
you have a predominant hormone uh which
one do you think makes you both
physically and mentally Who You Are
what if I told you estrogen's not a
hormone that you've been lied to
I wouldn't be surprised I'm not a
science person I know but think about
this though but here's here's what I
want women to understand about this most
women don't understand the biology of
what they have so therefore they don't
understand the physical and
psychological things that happen with
them so they think there's wrong or
watch this if they get abnormal it can
change their thinking a woman could even
think she's a guy we're gonna get into
that but hold the thing but ideas this
we're gonna get down there we're going
there okay
and here's what happens so so here's
what happens estrogen is not a hormone
estrogen is a term that represents many
hormones and when I realized with every
physical and psychological condition
that women were suffer with and even men
that they were not testing women
properly they weren't getting the
complete picture but they were making
judgments on people's physical mental
health based on incomplete information
so I started calling up Labs all over
the world say listen can we measure
things no joke I call the largest lab in
the world I said can we measure these he
said yes but why an insurance doesn't
pay for them and I'm like no I have a
very sick AKA girlfriend AKA fiance and
now my wife of 22 years
um that was very sick and then I started
to test and then I realized that guess
what now our female hormones not
described to women so they can make
great judgments what happened to them
physically mentally but they're being
misled and lied to and now of today now
today we're being lied to that abnormal
hormonal problems are actually should be
accepted as normal because if all of a
sudden here watch this if I were to take
synthetic testosterone and inject you
with that Pearl you would start to take
on male characteristics both physically
mentally and just because you thought
you were a guy I would say listen no no
you're taking a outside Source that's
going to cause you to think and act
differently even and biologically change
so see so good no so I have a question
about that so is it like when women are
in male dominated like Fields does it
elevate our testosterone at all because
I've I've wondered I've wondered if
there's some link between because I was
a super big tomboy like growing up I
just never was into the girly stuff but
I played competitive Sports so that's
like more of a male dominated industry
whenever you put your body into the
state of fight or flight or an anabolic
State like Athletics your tissues will
change they will and because remember
hormones by definition stand for
Messenger so for example if you are you
are starting to lift weights and you're
starting to do things that once again
you know males are supposed to do with
it comes to their characteristics your
body can force that production and it
doesn't that's why you've ever noticed
if women exercise like men they will
start to have a male type body but the
myth that they stop exercising to that
level they will start to get their
curves back that's why when I show women
that they exercise during the wrong
times because here's what happens so
let's go back to this so all of a sudden
to fast forward the story once I
realized Christy had some estrogen
problems the ones that the doctors never
looked for I started looking how to get
them back to normal and now what happens
is this we have four beautiful daughters
and all the current thinking said this
can't happen so 24 years ago when I was
24 years old I started applying this to
now men and women and it starts affect
them both physically inside ecologically
and then our clinical results started
and I was a poor country kid that
started one office to now actually
having wellnessway offices all over the
United States and now branch in Europe
and that because why because as people
say when they get good information and
then now makes life-changing things
people flock to it like crazy and we
need to actually get that kind of
information out there because it's
related so much to your stuff today
because here's what happens this if a
woman has a once again sometimes a male
dominated trait there can be some
hormonal balances to do that and when
you start to get them back to normal and
balance them they start going back to
their female characteristics and see
that's why if you ever know this you are
an athlete Pearl do you understand
because women don't know how to take
care of their hormones it's very common
for athletes to female athletes to skip
delay or even not have their cycle
because they throw their hormonal system
off so dramatically that they can start
to take that that's why you'll see them
become more manly and even more of a
manly body style until they get their
back normal
so
okay so it does because then my question
is like how how do you fix it then if
women would you say most women's
hormones are off now
um yes they're dramatically off okay now
so you have to look and go and here's he
started the right question instead of
actually asking how to balance them
because here's what happens you are
genetically programmed to have normal
hormones let me say it again so when
they're trying to say that I'm made this
way that I'm I I was born in this body
but I'm really this way I'm going no
that's not true let me explain for
example you let's say your testosterone
levels as a female would be let's say on
the average range of 25. okay mine's
supposed to be well above 5 500 okay I
know the ranges go a little bit lower
but that's because they allow
testosterone with too low males but
here's the point if you start taking
testosterone at levels to get up to 400
or 300 your body will change both
mentally and physically but the minute
that you stop taking that hormone what
does your biogenetically bring those
levels back down to roughly 25 okay so
really what happens is the question
should be is what is throwing off my
hormones what is the thing that actually
just corrupting them well once again I
always say there's three major stressors
that do it and I will actually tell you
the number one stressor I see that does
it and you're going to see this in
cultures like crazy number one for for
um when you look at the three things
let's call trauma toxins and thoughts
okay okay and therefore remember you're
an athlete you could do you could you
can physically hurt yourself create
inflammatory responses there's going to
be hormonal changes you can legitimately
once again have these things happen to
your body where there's a hormonal
reaction and you can really drain your
body of it if there's there's constant
stress on the body physically so that's
why women that exercise too much women
that actually are too athletic during
the wrong times because women's hormones
change four times in the month here I
want you to think about this about Pearl
the women do not understand this if you
look at a woman's cycle through the
month her estrogens and progesterones
circulate through the month and they're
different and I Look to say they're
different four times a month that means
a woman is mentally and physically
different four times guys let me say
something because I know there's a lot
of guys that watch your show when you
marry a woman you actually marry four
different women okay okay because
they're psychologically different every
week now on the flip side for you women
to understand this a little bit more
ladies there's one week that you'll get
up and put your bra on and it's all nice
and full next week you put your bra on
and a bunch of shriveled raisins okay
you're like what happened your body once
again physically changes each week now
why that is so important is this when a
woman exercises I've even written out a
chart when women can do high intensity
exercise when they shouldn't even think
of doing that whatsoever and women that
push themselves on a daily basis because
they okay I need to exercise at this
high level or even be a pro athlete or
an athlete you understand if you don't
know how to feel your body your tanks
are going to run out and that's when you
see all those cyclic changes so now
toxins you can eat horribly bad you can
put toxins on your skin you can actually
put toxic makeup all these things are
endocrine disruptors but guess what
those two are not as important as the
third one thoughts mental stress okay
mental stress drains and destroys female
hormones now watch this and here's a red
pill thing for you and here's where
here's where every aspect of culture and
feminism has hurt women
here by Nature if we look at your
progesterone which balances all your
good estrogens it converts into other
hormones called Cortisone and cortisol
see therefore when women go through high
mental stress they will deplete their
hormones when men go under stress
actually increases their hormones they
were biologically and physically meant
to handle stressors they were it's like
that's why and so that would to me talk
about a big red pill moment for
everybody is I'm just walking around I
don't care about your personal debates
and what people think I'm sitting there
trying to protect women by saying listen
it's my doubt to protect you from the
stress because it's going to physically
hurt you and lead to bad hormones which
is going to disrupt your life both
mentally and physique and you may end up
with infertility PCOS cancers mental
disorders all these things from just the
aspect of you're trying to enter a world
that can be very stressful and you're
supposed to be protected to because if
you're not protected you're gonna end up
sick
mm-hmm
so so trauma so women what screws up our
hormones is trauma toxins and thoughts
and the worst one is thought so high
stress high five uh why are the men more
feminine now
okay it's very simple let's go through
the basic biology of this okay and let's
let's let's put on a stat and then we're
gonna work backwards okay one out of
every 100 breast cancer diagnosis now
are males
okay very simple statistic now what does
that have to do with all things going on
here well here's what happens
testosterone is a very aggressive a very
competitive a very laser focused it's
what it does for us that's it's it's a
beautiful thing and it's being treated
like it's bad unless you're in sports
guys I understand this Sports is the
only thing men are allowed to be men on
anymore but if they try to put it into
the work world or the home world or
anything like that now it's toxic not
like going you are working it yes but
think about this now the majority of
testosterone for guys is very simply
made you need a couple brain hormones
and some ingredients some cholesterol uh
and we'll get to that some cholesterol
some zinc some other things and you can
produce the hormone testosterone but
here's the problem
I can show you thousands thousands and
thousands of labs where they'll come in
low testosterone and because our current
health care System doesn't say all right
what we're going to do is just gonna
give you now synthetic testosterone
which is very detrimental he'd need to
go why this is off where did it go
because it's produced but just like
certain hormones so they can convert the
forms so what they'll do is they'll try
to like fix it by putting in a drug but
they don't talk about like
problem was
and I'm gonna show you the number one
problem okay and this is and you're
gonna notice this and it's going to hit
home to most people if you look at for
example that testosterone's I'll produce
and now instead of doing the the factors
it does what happens is we do things to
our bodies that once again can cause
those hormones to be depleted and
converted and they can convert to
estrogens and then what happens is now
wait estrogens are more female dominant
yes males can convert their testosterone
into estrogens and one of the major
factors that do that is the over
consumption of sugar
because sugar now causes the aroma
tasting of testosterone really so too
much sugar makes men more feminine
yes because what it does well here let's
do this let's change that phrase a
little bit just so we stay within
biology okay when testosterone once
again when we have an over consumption
because remember our body runs on sugar
but people do too much of it especially
males because when males are stressed
out just like females they like to eat
they do things that way but they don't
grab here watch this Pearl I I know
you're a little bit but I imagine this
you've been through stress you've been
through things and if you're stressed
out you go to your people go oh man I'm
just so stressed out I just crave an
organic salad no you see no that's the
point yeah see we always because our
body runs on sugar We crave more sugar
things the sad part is we over consume
it we need sugar so don't think I'm
against sugar we need it but the sad
part is what we do now is we end up
having these things that now over
consume which now causes certain things
happen in our body it converts to
estrogens and now if I were to give this
we know this if I were to now inject
synthetic estradiol in a guy he will
start to take on all the what kind of
characteristics female characteristics
it will start to gain breasts you'll
start it's already happening without
hormone therapy look at man bodies today
the the dad Bob guys I'm sorry your
dad's disgusting
why is everyone so fat like it's the men
and the women everybody's it's like fat
fat fatties you know everywhere so it's
like why why are there whales it's like
whales everywhere
is it is it the food supply because it
wasn't like that a hundred years ago
like what changed it wasn't it wasn't
our food has changed but our environment
has changed dramatically too let me give
an example okay now I can pull up a
great Journal of nutrition that way and
and show you that for that just even the
hormones that can cause weight the
hormones that can cause other conditions
there you know we have we have we have
uh taken certain foods that they think
are good but they're they're not that
great and if you look at having some
form of soy uh you know and they're
giving babies soy formulas and they're
giving and they're causing hormonal
disruptions and things like that at a
young age so it's bad
I I I encourage especially men but also
women that have any kind of estrogen
problems uh to avoid it because there
can be some negative effects to it that
can relate to hormones and see here's
what happens when you look at hormone
disruptors there's so many multifactual
things I mean the fact this no joke I
will say in my clinical experience of 24
years and I've looked at and I will and
I'll underestimate I've looked at well
over a hundred thousand female hormone
labs done properly that mental stress
really dominates them men it's actually
their their habits now men with mental
stress can can mess up some things but
what it does for them it also helps
their testosterone because it's
aggression if I were to attack I saw
your studio your the man setting up your
studio before you started and guess what
happens if I were to attack him his
testosterone would jump up if I were to
physically attack you your female
hormones who make you are will start to
deplete see I'm saying so there's
multiple things that can happen but we
are affected similar in a couple ways
and I believe that how we you know I I
you know I've said this it's an old
saying you are what you eat I don't want
to put rotten Lumber into a house I want
to build it's going to affect you
psychologically and physically so I
always want to stay more on uh because I
don't like to debate about emotional
stuff I like to stay of course Hey
listen that when you see estrogens
Elevate in a man you're going to it's
going to express feminine
characteristics okay it does so your
argument is not yours anybody's argument
um that says well no no it's not about
yeah it's all biological so I recently
had this
I recently had a a young lady who was 18
years old
um she wanted to take she believed that
she was a boy and I'm not going to sit
there and argue with people I will tell
you this Pearl I've sat across fees for
for way before it became even popular I
sat across from people that thought
they're transgender even 20 years ago
and they truly believe it they truly in
their heart believe it okay and I sat
across this young lady that thought she
was a boy I even I just because this is
me I'm just a
Christian person so I believe every I
believe everybody gets respect in my
view regardless of we have different
beliefs and so I even called her by her
guy name okay and here's what happens
this
I said to her and the the now that her
parents sent me control of her she wants
to start taking hormone therapy okay and
I said could you do me a favor can I see
your hormone labs and she goes well I
never had you done I said wait wait so
they're gonna do which they consider
ethical which I think is disgusting
they're going to start putting synthetic
hormones in you to try to transition you
can you do me a favor can we at least
get your Labs because if your
testosterone levels are normal and they
give you to three four hundred go see
what happens to women if those levels
get elevated that for a long period of
time PCOS other Androgen type conditions
that lead to diseases and even cancer so
how is it as a doctor we take an old
first Do no harm we'll get this
we had her labs done she was already
testosterone elevated
what was she asking she said 25 was
normal what was she at well you can go
as high as 48 based on your lab ranges
that way but she was at like 90. which
would be double the ranges
so of course if you look at her I'm so
curious what mine would be I'm like so
curious because I feel like mine's
probably elevated because of all the
sports I did like I feel like it
probably is go ahead and it can be
because here's what happens during
Sports you guys feel this when you
aggressively push yourself your adrenals
are going to reach certain cortical
steroids certain cortisol certain
testosterone certain epinephrine and the
thing is all those things are measurable
so all I started to do when it started
with my wife 24 years ago I said you
suffer from these physical mental things
let's measure it so now if you believe
you're transgender what's guess what you
can believe what you want here watch
this ladies people want to argue this
well it's just a belief well ladies let
me ask you a question let's just look at
even if your cycle is normal there's no
hormone problems you change four times
in a month you experience different
things every week based on your hormone
levels you understand hormone levels
actually get you to view the world the
way it is because if your levels are low
if your levels are low it's going to be
depressed levels you will see the world
as a depressive bad thing
see it changes the view so how could
person not think they're a boy or girl
or something like that see I don't have
those arguments that go let's just
measure hormones and everyone I've ever
dealt with remember and I have hundreds
of doctors I have trained thousands of
doctors so I'm not just one little
clinic okay I've actually started to
speak in this and I speak on all stages
medical natural uh political all these
things say hey guys let's stop having
emotional arguments let's look at the
biologies people because maybe they're
suffering on the inside because when my
wife was said you can't have children
there was something internally that she
had no control over ladies you know this
you have no control over it and
therefore you think there's something
wrong women don't realize as their
emotions go up and down they're like Doc
I feel like I'm all over the place I'm
like good that's called being a woman
what week are you in
and women come and go doc you gave me
mental peace because see unlike guys
testosterone levels go up and they stay
very the same most of the time they only
have a little change then we have a
little change in the morning okay and
testosterone's a little bit higher in
the morning than it is at night time
ladies how could you tell that on your
man
he wakes up in the morning and guess
what happens it's out of his control I'm
saying he has disappointing erection
it's a good thing yeah you're saying and
see but see see you would laugh about
this but we know this and now I'm
speaking so everything I just talked to
you about you go look up in a book but
ladies you change four times in a month
and it you always ask uh Pearl I
absolutely love your show and you always
you always ask a question and say you
know what do men and women have wronged
by each other well and they give all
these answers and I love all their
answers I absolutely do but my
perspective is totally different
it's very difficult to understand a
woman when you don't understand their
hormones that they change every week and
so when you go into a relationship you
have to understand that you're going to
deal with four different individuals
every single month and what women do
what men do they go well she's all over
the place I'm like yeah it's called
being a relationship with a woman now
they're wrong yes if there's bad
hormones it's dramatic it's all over and
there's there's there's major issues but
we have to understand that these homo
effects are very biological it can lead
to some very devastating things can you
talk about this is something I wrote
down from earlier you said you were
diagnosed with Asperger's and then like
they you know
because I know a lot of great counselors
that give diagnosis as in psychiatrists
of that and I was explaining my history
okay no my history back then as a
counselor they said I was a juvenile
blink went that was what they called me
back then okay
um because of my behavioral because
here's what happens is I would sit there
and I would bounce I couldn't focus I
actually no joke I I couldn't read I
read my first book when I was finally in
high school uh because as I started to
change my internal things my psychology
started to change and I started to
change myself and I started to change
everything yeah so in a way like you
were diagnosed I forgot the word you
used but you you had a diagnosis of like
an issue and you fixed it through food
yeah well I fixed it through many
reasons number one I started to find
those stressors to my body and I started
to give my body what it needed in order
to grow and repair you know we look at
this we look at uh one thing I want you
to talk about which is very devastating
which our whole world has been misled by
even over in your country we have
correlated so much uh problems with
cholesterol that we don't understand
that every cell in our body especially
our brain needs cholesterol so they put
men on statin drugs they by Nature lower
one of the major building blocks to
testosterone and other hormones that's
why if you look at some of the negative
side effects of certain medications they
can lower hormones because they
interfere and disrupt some of the body
that way so what happens is this so I
said listen if I want to keep my
testosterone good I need certain things
that my body including cholesterol which
is contr indicated for most people's
beliefs in cholesterol and so here's
what happens that's why when you see
statin drugs taken at a high level you
start to see dramatic changes in
testosterone dramatic ones that are low
see so we talk about there's more than
there's more things that disrupt it so
then you have to look and go okay listen
if I want to feel my body to be athletic
for example if you're a viable player a
basketball player a swimmer and you are
intensely working out every single day
athletes are not taught how to fuel
their body here I have walked in with
many sports professionals sports teams
uh pro golfers and some of that and
you'd be surprised how bad they eat you
can walk into an NFL stadium and they
have cereals and all these things that
are very detrimental and actually even
working against and I look at going you
want your body to run at a high level
yes you're putting crappy feel into it
it doesn't make any sense when you think
about it it's like when you the life of
an athlete like I used to work out like
four or five hours a day so I like
because I would do two sports so I'd do
a three hour practice and a two hour
practice what time do you really have to
cook you just grab stuff
yep so and the sample is this but
imagine this that is your high
performance machine do you understand
that people if if they bought a high-end
car they're not putting crappy fuel in
it right we we look at things we put the
best in our houses we put the best in
ourselves but when we've so been
convinced and I believe that's the
Matrix and stuff that they need you sick
because Health Care is one of the
biggest businesses we saw that over the
last three years and stuff of that and
The Sapphires and we missed they misled
people in the very wrong direction and
believe it or not what they did to
people the last three years made them
very sick made them very sick so it's
really saddened so not only it's like
removing those stressors let's call it
the three T's I always call it three T's
because it gives people something to
work on but then we need to actually
figure out which each person's buy needs
and everybody needs something a little
bit different because without it always
remember this Pearl if hormone
imbalances are there there's physical
and psychological consequences to the
fact of major diseases but also major
psychological things and so when it
comes to some of the things things when
I watch people debate about the whole
transgender thing my first thing is I'm
empathetic towards them because if they
have hormone imbalances
how they view the world how they see the
world how they see other people you know
how they see themselves dramatically
changes because that's what estrogens
that's what testosterone that's what
dopamine that's what serotonin does to
the brain and if it's in Balance I'm
empathetic and very sympathetic for them
because they're suffering
what do you think I always think they
have like a mental disorder do you think
I'm wrong
um well let's let's make this
um a little bit more understandable so
people know what that means okay now for
example if we look at normal biology and
normal physiology there's going to be
certain levels of hormones and tissues
and things like that that change and
adapt to all the things that go on but
Pearl you know this if you hit your if
you exercise like you're doing four
hours a day and let's say you're let's
say you're progesterone depleted it
could actually affect your cycle you
could skip it you could delay it could
have your periods it could be all these
things but those same hormones those
same chemicals that just come generally
those same neurotransmitters also are
affected in the brain so there will be
an imbalance so will there be a mental
manifestation that's not normal so if
you want to call that mental disorder
sure because that's what would be
considered
I wanted
but it's so but it's like the more they
feed into it they just make it worse and
what someone could have been fixed now
they're like a crazy person
right and instead of this instead and
this what drives me nuts is we are
instead of saying Hey listen
something's wrong they want you to
accept it as normal and I can't Pearl I
can't that's like that's like this here
here I'll give you a simpler example and
this drives me nuts do you understand
that if a young lady gets her cycle and
she's cramping and blowing all these
problems and the doctor gives her a
diagnosis of PMS it's like it's so
common that we accept it as normal and
here's what happened made my book an
international bestseller it's called I
disagree do not confuse common with
normal they've been doing this for a
long time here if you if a fellow woman
came up to you said ah you know Pearl I
have my psycho I'm bloaty I'm crampy
stuff of this it's called PMS
premenstrual syndrome it's not called
premature normal it's just that we
accept this normal because it's so
common and now with with mental
disorders and mental things we're trying
to make people accept it as normal no
it's not normal there's a lot of the
stuff like depression anxiety all that
stuff like something is wrong and a lot
of times it's fixable but they'll throw
drugs at the problem
well yeah because here's what happens
this if I was a business and I could
actually convince you that you need to
take this rest your life and you're
stuck on it you have no control do you
understand the reason why they have
convinced people they have they it's
genetic and and all these things because
then it's out of your control and you
have to come to a Smart experts and we
will tell you what you need to do the
rest of your life and guess what happens
it doesn't get anything better and they
have a customer for the rest of your
life it's a medical matrix it's a
medical Matrix that keeps these people
medically enslaved in the aspects of
stuff and I'm sorry but I've seen this
and and and and the doctors hold sorry
believe it say you need to take this
stat and Drug the rest of your life well
if you believe that cholesterol is a
problem and it's elevated why is it off
why I listened to to these recordings
from like the 1900s and it was like um a
project on on slavery right and they
like recorded the um guys that like were
former slaves like their their
experiences as slaves right and the guys
were like 90 100 years old 110 and it
was kind of crazy how a hundred years
ago they were so mentally like clear
where if I speak to someone that's like
like they made perfect sense where if I
speak to like my grandma is a bit sick
now and it's like speaking to her it's
you can just tell it's like a little
cloudy she's not all the way and it was
it blew my mind how a hundred years ago
there was not nearly as many medical
advances I I would think but these these
guys were like genuinely so like their
minds were so clear I I don't know if
that makes sense
well of course it does but if you look
at what's happened over the time we live
in a more toxic world uh I'm talking
even just for example this I know it
sounds uh funny ladies but I want you to
think about this if you understand
the majority of your audience I mean
this very very nicely but they enjoy
your audience I've watched your girls on
your show you're the first thing I think
about when I see all the girls all
dialed up in all their makeup man they
put a lot of toxic endocrine things on
their skin that's going to absorb in and
it's going to cause endocrine
disruptions that's going to make them
both physically and mentally off okay
tell me what I mean now watch this here
watch this if you look at here people
give them women to come and say Doc I
don't know why I'm sick I say okay you
got this morning what did you do well
you showered well did you have a filter
on or just shower and chlorine well
chlorine okay toxin okay did you brush
your teeth yes did you use Crest Colgate
and all the other toxic toothpaste yes
okay uh did you shampoo yes toxic did
you did you actually put makeup on yes
okay all junk toxic okay all right
there's all good forms these things okay
but now let's do this uh what'd you have
for what you have for uh breakfast oh I
had a bagel or their gluten all other
things that are are inflammatory and
then I had a soy latte okay there you go
any good disruptor also this and then
what happens then I went to work and I
stressed out like crazy and I didn't
sleep well and then people go I wonder
why I'm sick
and he's in and see that's the thing if
you go back like you said a hundred
years ago they didn't what everything
they didn't have that stuff now they're
wrong and that's why greatest term
what's that what's switched
um convenient here watch this let's
start here okay you know this you know
this you just gave me this answer food
has been transformed from quality to
speed
because why busy lives do you see I'm
saying right and if you look at if you
look at this let's even go at makeups
makeups any product they're trying to
make cheaper and faster but you can get
a good you can get a good eyeliner a
good a lotion a good uh skin cream good
everything it's just that when you use
better ingredients it costs more so
people have moved everything towards
speed convenience and cost instead of
quality okay and it's it's sad because
it's hurting them and I come along and
say Hey listen you have all these
endocrine disruptors and then on top of
it ladies after all those things you do
you enter a world and here and I'm going
to say this I'm going to say this and
this uh once again will appeal to you
but it might not appeal to a lot of
people if you look at the business world
now I start out it's not a joke Pearl I
start out with 500 that's it I had a
good idea I had a heart to help women
especially with their hormones and I
built an international company 500 I
didn't come from a rich family I was I
started from nothing way and I built it
up but you know what happens this I
built it up because I had some very
common characteristics once again of a
male because here I'm going to give you
an example and I try to tell people this
all the time if you look at the
characteristics of a male that once
again help them in the world of business
competitive you know a confident
decisive
um laser focus all these factors which
oxy testosterone traits
see that's a competitive and that's why
people say well a page record no here's
what happens Society is built on those
things because you know what competition
does here watch this Pro you're an
athlete if you are competitive you're
going to get the best of the best people
and if you're not competitive with
yourself you don't get the best so you
need competition and psychology
competition to make quality to make all
the things that are good in the world
let's see what's up is this that is
mainly a male dominated trait so now
women which actually have their
estrogens give them much different
qualities nurturing compassionate caring
peace all these things I watch these
guys I watch these guys do this now and
I've always told this because my whole
hormone seminar is I understand the
physical and psychological thing is a
woman and I say women I've said this for
20 years say listen a man goes out and
is competitive and I actually know a lot
of good professional athletes they go
there knowing that their job is going to
be stole from them every day if they
don't stay at a high level so last thing
that they want to do is come home and
compete at home they need that nurturing
that peace that stuff like that and and
here's happens and that's the that's the
elements of a woman so I tell people
Society is created by the by the
conditions the testosterone of men
and homes and nurturing and all the
things that everybody needs including
kids including men themselves are based
at but now what they're trying to do
they're trying to take their home life
and make it into the world life and
they'll never succeed because when you
hear because you know why because a
compassionate mom doesn't want to see
another child lose in general remember
speaking about generals not exceptions
see because a lot of times people like
topple exceptions to rule this probably
may be exceptional you may be yelling at
your future kids going come on let's go
the average mom is not that way so
therefore is this so then guess what
happens so they say we want everybody to
win if you bring that into the Work
World guess what happens you're gonna
get destroyed
so all based on biology women want
everyone to win that's really true and I
can even say that like being a girl in
business like I I help my dad helps me a
lot because I'm just not very good at
making like Cut Throat decisions you
know and sometimes you really have to
um okay so what okay what do we eat like
there's this new trend on Twitter called
carnivore is that I had a carnivore lady
on my show and she was saying that she
eats like 10 eggs in the morning and I
was like wow it's a lot of eggs is that
the way the world's going carnivore
okay so so let's look at this and
remember my education background where I
initially went to college for was
nutrition okay so we're gonna get to
that world so here's what happens
um I just did I just did a video when
viral on this on my Instagram and I
people say Doc do you like carnivore
diet well people think I like the
carnivore diet because if you look at
any nutrition book across the world you
still look at any research the most
nutrient dense foods in the world are
organ Meats by far okay now I'm fasting
right now which fasting is phenomenal
for men not for women not for women men
and women are different okay but the
idea is this so I'm not going to have
liver today but I usually have some
liverwort so I usually have some organ
meat every single day which would be
considered carnivore but see here's what
happens this most of the carnivore diets
they really look at just muscle meats
and if you look at the biology of of the
world you ever look at an animal if an
animal attacks another animal the
dominant lion guess what he eats first
the organ Meats organ meats are by far
the most nutritious and then the rest of
the tribe the rest of the pack gets all
the muscle Meats Okay so when you look
at history nutrition organ Meats were
always the main thing they ate actually
go back to you know go back to you know
times and go back to you guys history
even over in England everything remember
royalty got the organs all the other
people got the muscles because they're
the most dense nutrient things on the
planet all right now do you need more
than that absolutely so do I believe
that people miss their vital nutrients
because of this whole aspect of not have
meat sure to do meat is extremely
important I would like to see a
combination of of certain things like
organ Meats some muscle Meats things
that have high fiber see that's where I
differ I think that we need I am a big
fan of fiber-based foods because also
helps regulate your blood sugar that's
why I like sauerkraut and other fibers
and Chica root and things like that that
can be put in our diet on a regular
basis because fiber is extremely
important the bad part is this is we've
actually been convinced that our good
fibers come from our grains nah I'm not
a fan of grains I really am not um so
therefore because if we look at some of
the things the Obesity and stuff that we
can actually get our blood sugars up too
high remember you need sugar you do but
people over consume it they do they just
have too much of it so here's what
happens so do I believe that people
would do a little bit better if they
moved a little bit more carnivore yes
but you still need your fiber-based
things and fermented foods so I tell
people once again reduce the overall
consumption of your sugar that's gonna
help both men and women okay
now once again you still need sugar let
me just tell you because you remember
because you need to you in keeping your
calorie intake down is pretty good
because calories just a unit energy and
we actually make sometimes consume too
much they need you need good fibers you
really do and that's why I'm big on that
you need good organ Meats uh you need to
actually one thing I also do like is
Sprouts because Sprouts are very good
they have certain chemicals in
um there's a chemical in one of my
favorite Sprouts broccoli Sprouts that
they try to patent as a drug go back to
it's well documented they tried to
patent sulforaphane as a drug because
its effect on cancer but it went to the
Supreme Court in the United States and
they could not patent it because it's a
natural substance natural substance are
extremely extremely powerful there's an
old saying that the whole world knows
you know that we talk about is that food
by that be thy medicine but let medicine
be thy food we need to start eating our
medicinal herbs and things like that
that actually help our body do things so
those are some Basics so as long as I
can I've always been
real at one time
I think I was too fat so I just I just
ran a marathon
in like three months I just decided I
was gonna do it and I could just do it
so I've always been really good overall
at training right I mean some years are
better than others but I've never and
I've been basically like the same weight
since high school like I really haven't
I gained a lot of weight right after
college because I was it wasn't working
out four hours a day anymore you know
but once I adjusted to that got back
down whatever how do you because I just
feel like I don't even know what life is
like without being addicted to Sugar I'm
like I don't even I feel like I've tried
so many times to like cut it or and I
just I have been so incredibly
unsuccessful so how do you how do you
fix your eating like that
okay so here's what happens think about
as a doctor
um I don't care if you're a male or a
woman like I said uh sugar is very
palatable sugar actually is very
mentally uh um satisfying that's why
when we're stressed what do We crave so
you have to do this you have to uh you
know compensate as I tell people for
their sassy habits Let me Give an
example I kind of I kind of gave it
right there if you are going to consume
some sugar once again I'm not going to
encourage it but do this you need to you
need to do the things that negate the
aspects of sugar so that's why fiber is
Big that's why you ever look at a
product it could say on the back it
could say four grams of sugar but it has
four grams of fiber it negates the sugar
aspect okay second of all watch this
this is so basic and basic research if
you were to just jump online and type in
an herb called gymnema okay let me spell
for you g-y-m-n-e-m-a
see what happens is there's constituents
within that herb that bind onto your
sugar receptors so therefore there's no
lock and key the lock and key is taken
up by that acid and therefore as sugar
comes through the absorption system it
can't and you just kind of poop it out
so you get the you get the mental aspect
of having something sweet for all the
taste buds that way but your absorption
goes down okay also once again you can
compensate once again with some physical
activity see so there's always a balance
you have to if you're sassy in one area
you better be darn good another it's
just that the majority of people are not
taught that they're saying Hey listen ah
get obese eat a lot of sugar I'm going
to give this this drug called insulin
and if you if you actually look at your
country over there ten percent of your
budget goes towards medical things that
are your guys the England oh you know
which is American right
yeah yeah so so is that so I know
because you're from you're from the
Midwest I'm from Chicago exactly so we
grew up only three hours from each other
yeah the idea is this but what you think
about this and the reason why I bring
this up is because people have this
arguments like people with arguments
between you know transgenders or choice
and it's not a choice and they argue
about that way well we have these
arguments when it comes to health care
of socialized medicine compared to
private pay and all stuff like this I'm
like listen if you have a bad idea it
doesn't matter who pays for it right you
can have you could have to pay for it or
you can pay for it it's still a bad idea
you know Sam you have over here private
paid insulin or over there in England
insulin guess what happens it's still a
bad idea because you're just Paladin
people's bad behaviors that they need to
actually adapt their lifestyle to right
so again what are your what are your so
your tips with your addicted to take Jam
number one number one what I do is once
again start with fiber because you can
counteract a lot of your sugar
absorption and your things from fiber
okay number two may you could take some
things like genema you can compensate
with some things like Goldenseal or
Berry Bear there are things that you can
do that will but once again those are
just natural compensations for bad
habits okay
um and then physical activity is very
important obviously because you're going
to try remember there is a little bit of
you know obviously sugar has calories so
does everything else have calories you
want to you know obviously try to reduce
that calorie intake because the unit
energies you can only spend so much
energy here per day but you can increase
your energy movement and watch this
think of this way you can stimulate
thyroid effect by something so simple
and I have women do this all the time
laziness is so simple and so easy to do
for example get this do you understand
that's something that's very popular
right now is ice bass okay now let's
think about yes what happens well you
ever you ever look at even swimmers in
general what they do is they jump in
actually cold water because the pools
are 68 degrees they seem like they're in
great shape yes there is physical
activity but you understand the loss of
heat the transfer heat from the from the
body to the water is dramatic and then
your body starts to kick in Kick in once
again
um your thyroid which is one of your
major hormones that produce uh like T3
for metabolism well guess what happens
so if we can lower the body temperature
that's why it seems to help women with
weight loss or even men but I want to
show you something easier much easier
it's called the mammalian diver reflex
do you understand that the majority of
our cold receptors are not on our body
they're on our neck and head so you can
actually do this and this is good for
stress this is great for stress because
they show that when you uh you put your
head under water Your Body by Nature
starts to slow its heart rate down puts
it in a calming state so what you need
to do every morning wake up get a good
old bucket of ice water and put your
head under water and try to hold your
breath for a little bit that will help
you with metabolism that will help you
with calming neurotransmitters that will
help you with dopamine they'll help you
with your thyroid
what's that do you do that in the
morning you like dunk your head
I actually dunk my whole body and I
actually the whole I if you ever see go
back to my Instagram you'll see me now
I'm fasting right now women don't fast
whole another thing it's all that's they
they got this totally wrong men it's
essential for their hormones to fast
it's essential for their life to fast
um women it's going to destroy your
hormones and Destroy some things now
what's going to detail that but that is
this you bet your butt I jump in like
this morning I threw I had a bucket of
ice it's still cold over here you know
it's like in the midwest or in April and
I jumped in there I try to stand there
for at least uh three to six minutes
um and no ideas then I actually there's
ice in there I brought my head under and
I hold my breath and I calm myself and
it's fantastic you get you get dopamine
response you get epinephrine
norepinephrine and it's known
psychologically to keep that brain
aspect for at least six to eight hours
some of the greatest neurologists
neuroscientists in the world we'll talk
about that so you can actually do that
even if you don't have a whole bucket
you could be a person that lives in an
apartment just get uh just get a big old
you know bucket or I'll take a saucer
pan you know a cooking pan put your head
in there and women come back say Doc oh
my goodness it actually um it actually
helps with anxiety now watch this it's
funny because one of my one of my uh
investigative journalists in here she
has three daughters okay and she's
sitting right here when she was I
remember when I was in full-time
practice I only see a couple females
right now just because I love still
practice that way and I do I do still uh
when a parent or a person calls me and
they're they're going through things
like they transgender they believe
they're different sex I will take them
on just because I have experience with
it and so in my other docs but I I have
a heart for it that way because of the
hormone problems but when they when they
had three daughters and they're young I
said listen an easiest way to change
your kid's state is take a glass of
water and throw it in their face
throw in the face it changes them right
away the water itself puts it just like
you when you go underwater your body
goes into it tries to slow itself down
in order to calm itself down so remember
and I was a kid that dealt with major
sensory neurological immunological
issues and so that's why when I keep my
face underwater I jump in there there's
not only a neurological component
there's a metabolic component so
therefore ladies you will actually cause
an increase in output of your thyroid
which now which will lead to better
metabolism and do it in the morning do
in the morning you have a circadian
rhythm your hormones are supposed to
jump up very high in the morning for
everybody and that gets you going most
women are running an empty fuel tank
they are and affects them both
psychologically physically and leads to
a lot of problems both marital
relationship and also them personally so
what
more food question and then I want to
ask about that so in a given day like
what is the perfect like things that a
man should eat versus a woman should eat
yeah they are they are different they
really are okay it's like breakfast what
should girls eat should guys not eat
because they should be fasting
um here's what happens if you look at
the Circadian rhythm now here's what
happens I would never generalize that
advice with all lab let me explain why
okay if a person actually has extremely
high cortisol in the morning on the lab
a woman has to eat because once again if
they fast in the morning that's going to
drive their cortisol up and their stress
hormones to be more and that could be a
problem in general so let's speak about
the general rules
um both men and women can skip breakfast
the concept
um
um the concept of breakfast syndrome
you're more insulin sensitive and more
and you can handle sugar bear in the
morning there's no doubt physiologically
but that's because your your your body
actually starts to you know bring its
hormones up it's a little more attentive
to the world but the idea is this is
when you look at somebody that has
extremely tanked hormones in the morning
it's better for them both males and
females to fast
um now women men can fast all day women
have to start eating by noon I'm saying
because now otherwise their their
hormone system is going to be directly
off so if you look at it happens look at
what we need as far as repair of our
body as an athlete okay you're gonna
need a lot more proteins and sugar than
the average person you do because
remember you are what you eat you have a
significant amount of proteins you have
a significant amount of fat in your body
and then we have very little
carbohydrates in our body so if you look
at the way we eat today we're dominant
carbohydrates yeah we're we're we're
we're we're we're low and and proteins
and we're really on fat because we said
well that's bad for us well considering
that the majority of your brain is made
of fat
fatty acids I kind of find that kind of
contradict indicate that that's why like
number once again my education obviously
went to undergrad was nutrition and here
there's a there's a big argument with an
egg well an egg is an extremely
extremely extremely bioavailable protein
source and decent fat Source but I will
tell you this here's something that's
gonna going to throw off and this is why
people need to search out individual
health individual injury Doctrine is I
just told you that about an egg based on
the education base I can prove that
scientifically I can give you every
research on there but if I eat it it
could kill me
because I have an egg allergy
see so therefore I can't have that
that's why that would be inflammatory
for me it would even hurt my hormone
levels see that's why personalized
Health Care has to be there that's why
when someone says this drug is good for
everybody or this
thing over the last two years they gave
everybody's good for everybody and
trying to make sure we don't get kicked
off and uh the idea is this is it's so
unindividualized so if we look at what
you need and think about this and here's
one thing that's going to really throw
the answer off even more ladies you
change every week your diet what you
consume needs to change weekly that's
how detailed I am about building
people's bodies and really specific
because
really
yep it is and so I try to enter on we
have I could speak on this for hours you
can go to my you know Instagram page
I've been I'm just like you I've been
kicked off a ton especially during with
all stuff this way but people still seem
to find me and some of that but the idea
is this it's that detailed now but just
look at this way if you think in general
I talked about this I love fiber I love
Sprouts I love organ Meats I love just
uh certain remember we're talking
grass-fed good meats just to be clear on
that I'd never want to eat a processed
soy fed or corn-fred cow which is our
wheat fed cow that way that's
detrimental bad meat and therefore what
happens this so by putting those things
on a regular basis that way you're going
to give a lot of basic building blocks
but I agree my little girls since they
were one year old
um have been eating organ Meats since
they're little my daughter said my four
daughters my oldest daughter just got
married my four daughters have never
seen a doctor besides me they've had no
need for it and stuff uh so those are
things that I'd say to start with and um
and really look at the details what
needed for each person
do you do that you get
remember I always say this you know if
you look at even just look at this way
when you were playing uh um you know
college ball and things like that I love
your story of transferring and things of
that as is this is your teammate
actually needs to be tested because her
needs can be different than yours and
see and that's where I started to go
okay listen what does each individual
need let's run some blood work let's run
some stool work let's run some of your
work there's things and we can start
seeing the deficiencies because here's
what happens there's no person in the on
the planet that has ever developed an
illness because they were
pharmaceutically deficient
now but there are people
Even in our history if you're a vitamin
D deficient if you're vitamin E
deficient you provide an a deficient
vitamin K deficient can lead to Major
illnesses see I I find it so interesting
that our current form of dominant Health
Care is the myth somebody is sick they
never ask what it needs if I air watch
this if I have a plant right here if I
had a plant right here
um Pearl and it was starting to wilt
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind what's the first thing comes
to your mind about that plant water it
ah it needs water sunlight maybe the
cat's peeing in the soil right toxic
okay but here's what happens if you see
somebody that has anxiety depression
female hormone problems the first thing
that they are conditioned to run to is a
doctor that's going to give some
pharmaceutical agent to manipulate their
body and never ask what that person may
need or what's even like I told the
example of the cat peeing in the soil or
something toxic that could be wilting it
we are taught better to take care of
that plant since you were little than
your own female human body or male body
so how does this affect relationships
you said it affects how women and men
behave in relationships yes okay so
let's do this so so if we look at just
female nadding okay the minute that a
woman's body goes into fight or flight
it changes all tissues okay like I tell
people this mental stress can lead to
Progesterone and other uh hormone
deficiencies or even stress hormone
excesses that once again change them
both physically and psychologically that
they don't want sex here think about
this watch this
let's take a guy a guy could have a
horrible day at work which increases the
testosterone he could actually break his
toe he could actually and he'd come home
and say honey guess what happens just
this this and talk about his day and be
even stressed out for my an hour later
he'd be like probably one of six you
saying by Nature yeah now
physically and mentally what happens to
a woman's biochemistry it even changes
the vaginal secretions of a woman when
they're stressed out it even changes
their brain and their desire when they
are in fight or flight is dramatically
different that's why when a woman's
stressed out they're basically their
pains are super glued to them okay
because by Nature that stress actually
pulls out that desire of connection see
estrogens are very a connective hormone
and see when they're under stress they
lose that ability to connect by Nature
do you see him Sam and Duran guys I can
teach you this I do this all the time do
you understand here Pearl let me see a
question let's go this
who do you think stresses out more men
or women in general who do you think
stresses out more men or women women
who cause the women all stress
men okay now here it happens hey now the
reason why and see everybody last when I
say that and then women go hey it gets
kind of right but here's what happens
guys what if I told you that you could
be one of the greatest stress relievers
and health things to your woman and your
wife if you knew how to do it right if
you understood her hormones because by
Nature she's connected to everything
guys can be so laser focused they can
leave the house and they can realize
that they don't have kids or a wife
because what they're lazy folks they
dominate it's good right yeah
[Music]
but here's what happens women can't do
that they're connected to everything so
a guy has if a guy wants to be in
relationship that wife may have a
stressful day they may have something
going on what if I taught you told you
that there's things that you can do that
can bring her stress levels down and
bring her estrogens and bring her
hormone levels up that she can be
connected it's not that difficult it
really isn't it's just that guys are not
taught this stuff and women are once
again they're not taught how stress is
so bad for them because when they go
into fight or flight when they start
releasing cortisol and all the major
stress hormones in Adrenaline guess what
happens it steals away from their
biology to actually go into a a state of
fertility connection and that's why it's
very difficult for them to actually when
they're under high levels of stress so I
say guys it's your job to be to protect
your and create the environment that
leaves a woman in least level of stress
because by nature one of the major
aspects of us being the woman is sex so
don't be the stressor you're working
against the stuff that you Everly want
vice versa ladies don't put yourself in
major stressful situations from other
females and other situations that can
lead to Major stressful things including
how you take care of your body because
as by Nature the reason why a man is
with you in the first place is sex is
one of those things uh so that's why
sometimes I feel like guys
will try to keep you out of certain
situations so you don't get stressed out
supposed to that's actually the if if
you understood and here's as a doctor
and guys listen I just started to
understand the biology of hormones and
trying to trying to get my wife from
being infertile the fertile and
obviously and I've done that now that's
why I did my whole career after I
figured all this stuff out
but here's after this but then I
realized that by Nature that guess what
happens and this is biology we are
protectors and when you protect your
wife yes if you protect your wife from
the world
from from all the bad things that
they're not supposed to deal with you
essentially bring her into her female
characteristics that you love I watch on
your show that men say man I just want a
feminine woman then be the protector
that allows her to be in that feminine
situation and don't put her in the
stresses and sometimes we as men and
this is where the feminists go crazy we
need to even protect you from your
friends in other environments because we
understand that if you get stressed out
we actually are the non-beneficaries of
you being stressed out because you're
all stressed out we ain't getting sex at
night
and then every it's like when a girl's
stressed out we don't hide it well
that's like the whole family feels it
yeah but but here's what happens this
you know if you think this way a man's
supposed to be the mountain of the
emotional waves that crash into you it's
okay see this idea this idea that men
are not supposed to have handled
problems doesn't make any biological
sense to me because here by Nature no
joke on your show tonight or on your
show next show that way if you were to
if you're if you're if you're guards if
you're security was to even remove one
of those men
okay just by Nature guess what happens
since testosterone goes up because when
we go to fight or flight Here Comes our
hormones and that's what everybody knows
a guy is really aggressive he's turned
on he's turned on see it does the
totally opposite to women to the
opposite to women and if guys understood
so so when you always ask the question
what don't men and women are saying
about the other they don't understand
each other's hormones so they don't know
how to treat them here watch this you
say that but you even said that a guy
can leave and he can basically go
conquer deca's competition and all those
major characteristics but I want to
think about me a little bit well then
guess what happens if you stimulate his
testosterone to focus on you he can go
dominate the world but he'll think about
you and only you all day long
you know watch this if um ladies little
trick and you're gonna say Doc don't do
it because my husband may watch this
right now no no
tomorrow morning do this to your do this
to your to your man okay just go up
before he leaves he's gonna go conquer
the day be his biggest support honey go
dominate go be you you know what I'm
saying someone gets you away go do it
you you handle that you handle your
business
and then before he leaves just whisper
and see her and remember honey tonight
is going to be a good night
does that man think about
law he bought me he will probably text
you morning he's ever texted you before
because what you did you because here's
what happens Men by Nature produce
testosterone by thought sight and some
aggression and therefore you just
stimulate to think about testosterone
because testosterone is a very laser
focused thing and he will think about
this all day long and guess what happens
and if he understands the biology of you
he will come home and set the
environment of no stress so that by the
time that the kids go bad or by time
that's night time that way that guess
what happens it's good it's a good night
what do you think about like women
liking toxic men
like men like having to do like say I
hear this like men do you know
um sporadic or like toxic behaviors but
it's because like women like it
well here I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about
biology and let's go over this and it'll
make complete sense and you're going to
say wow when I'm you're gonna say wow
when I'm done with this okay okay
the the females who for for example love
toxic men are the women who actually
don't get to experience the true
femininity in the true hormonal Rush of
a feminine woman let me explain because
estrogens by Nature
put women into a very connective uh
wonderful response that gives them their
sex drive
but now if they have to act masculine
because they've been through trauma and
other things
their Rush of hormones of testosterone
comes from fighting in aggression and
that will stimulate them which will give
them a sex drive towards that person
just like a male
see so therefore the sad part is this if
a woman has to live and and I mean this
very nicely I mean this very nicely and
I don't want to talk about race but if
you look without a father in the
household and this does happen a lot in
African-American communities okay the
women have to take on male
characteristics in order to survive they
have to they have to supply they have to
handle stress so therefore their whole
life is based around getting that shot
of testosterone that gives them their
emotion like it does to a man so now if
they're now put into a feminine
situation because they come into a guy
that say listen I'm going to protect you
I'm going to support you that way and
that but their whole biology has been
triggered by emotions to look for that
Rush that anger that that that that that
thing that can drive the testosterone
levels up and a good protective a good
male isn't as appealing to them
and they don't understand that I might
say and people go holy I've talked to
psychiatrists going holy crap doc you
just answered the reason why women look
for that stimulant a toxic man is a
stimulant that gives them the biological
Rush that they had to deal with their
whole life that gave them some form of
satisfaction biologically
and holy psychiatrists are going doc you
freaking knocked out of the park with
that one right there I said yes so you
have to get women into more of a
feminine understanding that state and
and seeing that their body can and
mentally and physically can be better in
that feminist State than it ever could
be in an aggressive State what do you
play certain toxic characteristics
um it also means they can protect us so
if like a guy
but that's not toxic see if you look at
all the characteristics of man that's
not toxic it's femininity looking for
masculinity
yeah I just meant like okay for example
um violent offenders like prison
offenders
reproduce more
than like the average job so that like I
think we'd agree that a violent a person
that's committing violent crimes like
that's that's toxic
it's not a good well here's that yeah
right okay here let's go back to this if
you look at look at all the traits of
masculinity right uncontrollable
uncontrolled or violent right right
do you find me see what happens this
competitiveness and let's give you a
really stupid example but this does
happen let's say you're competitive in
business and one of your competitors is
being you there's been fiscal crimes and
murder against people like that once
again they took a they took a masculine
competition State way too far so so what
happens is this that's why if you ever
look at the fact that you know a person
that may have committed crime what
happens is they were uncontrolled now I
believe this see if you think of this
way is every guy has a major monster
inside of them but what happens is
because a good man will teach another
good man say listen and that's what
that's what happens this drives you nuts
it's really interesting how women would
be extremely disgusted if they actually
knew what we thought about all day long
you saying because you know I
because once again and women always say
they want the truth I'm like no you do
not you do not want the truth that's why
men have to talk to men about this stuff
right because it's what happens you'll
stress out your woman if you actually if
you told them what went through your
head every single day but see a
controlled man be that monster but
control it and that's what we're not
teaching men because we're teaching them
that their sexual desire get this my
daughter just got married I looked at my
I looked at my son-in-law who is a who
is a is a uh 28 year old stud okay and
my daughter is absolutely gorgeous I
said listen you're gonna look at her and
you're going to touch her boobs and grab
her butt every single day right now if
you touch her I'll kill you when you're
married have sex to your eyes pop out
you're saying and when they got married
I'm like I'm like when they got married
I sent my son-in-law I said dude we're
on a golf course I said guess what used
up all your testosterone sex last night
guess what your drives are not gonna go
as far as mine today
he said and we're on the golf course so
it's kind of funny and what I'm just
kind of showing is is that masculine
trait once again just had to be
controlled see we don't teach that
anymore you say we don't sit there he
goes hey young men guess what happens
you're going to go through all these
things control them they don't go away
ask and you're good men on a show those
drives never go away they're just
controlled so therefore that's a very
appealing so that's why I just got out
of prison okay what do they do they have
the same masculine traits that are
uncontrolled so stop calling stop
calling masking traits toxic you start
to call toxic people uncontrolled
emails so it's more on like it's
uncontrolled it's not toxic but watch
this watch this here's what happens I I
will tell you this I had a family owner
that was in prison okay I went and
visited him on a regular basis
I sat there with the moms so compassion
nurturing
if it's uncontrolled
they're like my boy's such a good boy
he's sitting in prison
he said in prison so your uncontrolled
femininity is being too compassionate
knock it off
that's why there has to be a balance of
it is that why like you know what's
weird a lot of times when I talk to guys
from single mother homes I can hear it
in their voice
and I don't know what it is and it's
also a thing I can hear in like female
athletes like voices in The Way We Carry
ourselves like I I know because a lot of
us are daddies girls I've just noticed a
lot of us are the oldest girls and we're
Daddy's Girls and where I've noticed
like with men from single mother homes
like I can hear it in their voice and
the way they like talk like they just
speak in a more feminine way
well here look at my daughters guess
what happens I'm still their hero days
are supposed to be that way days are
supposed to show the masculine traits
not only to the society to go and
dominate but also to remember a mask and
man can go Dominic take on competition
competence laser focus deciseness and
then come home and once again and be a
very good family man and the daughter
see that and you think that my oldest
daughter didn't actually go after a man
like that of course if my son-in-law is
just like me because my time off for
example is a doc just as they and and
guess what happens and people say I set
the standard uh-huh what I did is show
my daughter what a masculine provider
protector and things like that and my
daughter actually is going to be a
doctor just like me but I even told my
son-in-law you are there to protect her
from stress even sometimes from herself
so I'm teaching my son-in-law you need
to protect her from sometimes herself
because as she stressed herself out she
can very be very driven and she was an
athlete she was a great athlete top
state golfer amazing all the good things
like that she still loves afflecks that
way but she also knows how to take care
of her body so she doesn't miss her
cycle she doesn't skip her period She
doesn't have any psychiatric issues
she's very feminine
but that's what these guys and so I
figured all this out by just
understanding the biology the the
testosterone the estrogens the things
women how they affect both men and women
physical and psychologically and that's
why it's like
and I will be honest I reached out to
you I'll tell you I was I would tell the
crowd how I met Pearl yeah she mentioned
that she was having some health things
well as a male protective I'm like Pearl
you're doing wonderful things I
sometimes have to protect you from
yourself so you continue to do the great
things in the world so my advice to you
Pearl has always been things to protect
you and do you fight me on them do you
fight me on them Pearl be honest
okay I don't fight you I just don't know
how to like
I'm just even successful at it but here
but as a protector as a doctor to you I
have to give you advice even if you
don't like it or not
see that's what we do as and so I've
taken that transition into being a
doctor into being the father into being
a leader of a huge company that's
growing all over the world and guys
listen I started with 500 I employ more
women than men and I sit there and tell
them ladies you are not allowed to
stress out my company because it'll make
you sick
they'll make you sick
I don't want you sick I want you to
thrive and your characteristics I wanted
you to bring to a feminine quality to
certain aspects of the company
why the males Dominate and do their do
their athletic aspects to competition
because the business is kind you're dead
guess what happens he still has to
compete being a business owner but then
what happens is you marry you bring the
two together just like in the marriage
you bring the two together a
relationship bring two together in
health care and it's a beautiful thing
what
knowing I will say this because
everything's private yeah but knowing
your lab yes you do
I always do it do it for like two days
and then I quit it's not good it's not
but but when you do that you're two days
your body says thank you Dr Patrick for
giving me that advice
maybe I'm inspired after this I'll do
maybe I'll make it to 3
. okay hey I will take it I'll take it
um okay what are we talking toxins
trauma
uh what's your most controversial
opinion
um my most controversial opinion
actually this is this this got me kicked
off of media a little bit that way is
I'm gonna say it dramatically but I'm
gonna explain it physically and we
talked about it women are not mental
meant to handle stress okay
now let me explain I'm not saying for
example that they that and what I mean
by that as this is whenever stress gets
to a biological shift to where their
body goes into fight or flight and they
start producing stress hormones that
take away from their anabolic buildup
repair uh calming feminine hormones
you now are putting that that woman into
an Adaptive state that can lead to
illness both psychological and physical
and I just can't I can't do it I can't I
can't
I can't not talk about that because
here's what happens
if you understand that right now more
women take psychiatric medication ever
in history do you know right now that
women are more unhappy more infertile
more obese have more diseases ever in
history
yet the thinking perpetuates and they're
trying to do it more that they're
putting women in stressful situations
that lead to physical and psychological
ramifications that can be avoided if
they just understand that see people say
Doc but there's some people that can't
avoid stress but here's one thing that
they do though
see and they think when I say that that
I'm not saying that I'm saying women are
weak that's totally opposite I'm
actually telling you that women are
strong because if you can let them know
that stress can hurt them they will be
more because women are more intuitive
women are more perceptive of their
surroundings they will start to avoid
those stressful things they'll start to
they'll start to know that when their
body moves into a stressful state that
can only be there for a short time and
they'll make changes very quickly where
a man won't
okay so therefore bringing awareness to
women
and using their strength and allowing
them to be deductive and with the world
they have now better perception of what
to do
and they can use that being strong
because here's what happens
Pearl you may have to sometimes look at
this and go some that stressed in your
life and you have to realize that now
that you know it can hurt you you can
say no soy latte I'm gonna push it away
because that's a toxin you can say no
I'm not going to work out every single
day because the way no matter you have
to move every day but you're not going
to work on intensely ever say any push
that way but maybe it might do this
Pearl you may say no bad relative bad
friend bad boy bad anything in my life
that's causing me mental stress and now
that you are aware it makes you strong
because now you can say the most
important word that every woman needed
to know and it was the best doctoring
device I ever gave to a woman and I to
women in general is you have to learn to
say no
yeah
yeah struggle with as far
I feel like the
month I've had so much like
I don't know people dissecting every
part of my life online and it's just
been like crazy no like seriously and my
producer was what Earl I've been going
against the grain for 24 years let me
tell you a little story this is why this
honestly and totally being transparent
with you why I reached out to you
because here's what happens when I
propose to my wife all these ideas that
I was sharing 24 even longer than that
24 years ago I knew I was going to go
against the grain I knew it so I looked
at her and before and I got down one
knee and I said listen being married to
me will be the most difficult thing you
ever do in your life because I'm going
to share ideas that are going to go
totally opposite to what the world is
telling everybody but the world's not
going the right direction I believe God
gave me the strength and the idea is to
bring them to you and so therefore it's
going to be very difficult so I said if
you want to take this journey with me
marry me if you don't I understand Pearl
with your show you're going against the
grain and because they can't argue your
message they have to attack the
messenger
people are going to attack me right now
because I'm talking about female
hormones I'm not endocrinologist but
endocrinologists have led people down
this bad path
do you see what I'm saying other other
medical field people down the wrong path
so when you cannot argue the message you
have to argue the messenger so I want to
encourage you and I want to protect you
from that thinking that when people are
critical and tearing you apart
that means guess what
your information is affecting them they
don't want to sit down and have to
really sit down and go maybe I have to
change my thinking
so I'm going to tear on the tall six
foot girl that's not married and talks
to guys in in his this this I see the
criticism and when I see it I smile so
it's people like me that have a huge
platform on this side that I can't wait
to share the video so when they watch
your stuff that they are going to be
more encouraging to you
so that's the good part which would be
better for you no but I just I haven't
found
better
and where it's just been like nuts and
it's like I just have not found a good
way to deal with like the stress because
they start to like go after your family
they start to like it just it just gets
crazy and I'm like I I don't know
it's hard because I'm like I don't do
this yeah okay
to calm your brain down calm your brain
down I want you to take some California
poppy and some cat meal now everybody's
gonna research that now and they're
gonna see the calming neurological and
immunological and psychological effects
if you look at like Cameo has a little
ingredient in there called apogen
a-p-i-g-e-n-i-n and it actually slow it
actually will help the front brain even
calm down your thoughts a little bit and
stuff and see I'd rather have you things
like that than some psychiatric
medication to try to numb you yeah no
well I wouldn't do that but but because
the other thing I was gonna ask is like
um yeah I feel like we're all so
addicted to our phones now
and well
question for you I'm gonna I'm gonna
change this okay here's what happens
um
if you look at this way everything is
about awareness okay and right now the
easiest way to even find you find other
people is the phone yeah but the only
thing that he wants you to do so I look
at this remember people are going to try
to take anything and make it bad
whatever people didn't grow up with they
they think it's bad gotta remember if
you did when the TV came out um guess
what happens everybody said I was Satan
it was gonna destroy people's lives
whether it came out guess what happens
whatever you remember this whatever you
didn't have as a child you think is bad
right okay and now but here's what
happens there is there's one thing I
would like people to do is about an hour
before bed they need to put their form
down just from the aspect of melatonin
production okay so I I want you to you
know if you if you notice if you ever
see some of my videos I will have
certain blockers on certain glasses that
just block certain lights certain blue
light and everything so there's not a
stimulatory effect because once again
melatonin which helps us go to sleep
once again actually starts to cycle up
towards that 9 00 PM Mark and so you do
have that electronic around the area you
actually stimulate and you won't get
that production but I don't see anything
I don't see anything wrong with the
phone because guess what happens before
a long time ago instead of the phone it
was the radio or before the radio was a
newspaper before the before you know uh
internet it was TV I just feel like it's
good because like I've built such a cool
like show off of it and sometimes I'm
like I feel like it controls me more
than I control it and I think it's like
part of the reason I don't sleep as much
as I should and I'm up so late I mean
partially it's the show which I just
moved another hour earlier because good
thank you I just yes now now we're
almost I'm surprised
I'm surprised you didn't ask me that I'm
surprised you didn't ask me about sleep
because women need more sleep I did a
video that went absolutely viral that I
had scientists call me from all over the
world to explain what I meant by it and
they were they were blown away when I
gave the explanation but women need more
sleep than we than men because it's all
hormonal it's based on a circadian
rhythm it's based on hormone levels and
even build up of growth hormone and
ladies and I miss myself but you need to
be in bed for the best hormone
production between that times of 9 and
10 p.m and the later that you go to bed
the less hormone reserves less growth
hormone the less everything you do have
and that's why I get this I own a large
company and I've said this and this
drives feminist nuts but being a
protector of everybody of all women see
I'm a protector of women so if when my
company has to be open on third shift I
will make a rule and maybe this will get
me canceled but I will make a rule that
they cannot hire women for third shift
because what I see is a detriment to
their life in their health and it will
be a bad situation for them both
physically and mentally and I'm not
going to contribute to them being sick
I'd rather put men on third shift than I
would think now I don't think I'll ever
do third shift because I think men and
women both need to
um both need to
um
sleep so I probably on my own values and
understand I will probably never keep my
Warehouse open through third shift
because I can't I believe too much in
what I what I know
High School I learned about like a sleep
debt is that a real thing
um explain with you in high school I
remember I was in Psychology class and
they said like
so if you if you need eight hours of
sleep at night and you only get six like
then you occur a sleep debt so it's like
you need like four like well and they
said it's like weird though because they
said you couldn't make it up but then
you do sleep more later but it's not
like the same type of sleep like that
that's 100 right you don't you you
that's not cumulative it just here's
what happens is we just seem to talk
about what they're what they're trying
to tell you is this is if you get to bed
at midnight and even sleep till eight
o'clock and got eight hours you are
still gonna be more hormoneally
deficient than the person that went to
bed that that uh at nine and slept till
five because so here's what happens this
so and then when it happens is you
become so hormonally fatigued and you
actually have deficiency hormones that
your body just gives out and you sleep a
bunch but you still don't feel the
greatest see you need to and think about
the Circadian rhythm of when our
hormones speak up and when they come
down and then look at when we start to
build up our reserves well guess what
happens guys don't need the amount of
reserves as women
and they need less sleep and all I did
was say here's why women need more sleep
here's the scientific basic behind it
and and I got like 100 million views and
stuff like that and um and I obviously
once again Pearl I had because because
uh I had people that were women are
screaming at me about third shift I had
people this I said listen I'm just
putting out information for people to
digest and take and it's great and
because they couldn't argue the message
they had to yell at the what the
messenger right so I'm gonna continue to
encourage to put your message out there
and then what a man would should do the
man in your life should say pearl I'm
gonna protect you and you're not going
to read the comments I'll read the
comments and stuff for that because yes
is you guys are connective you see nice
about a guy because of testosterone
guess what happens every man now let me
talk about this for two seconds on here
every man because of testosterone
testosterone gives us great confidence
do me a favor in your studio tonight
look at the men and every man regardless
of his age because of testosterone
thinks he's amazing testosterone is a
very confident hormone yes I am so
that's why if you ever look at a man and
uh and and they seem so confident
there's flexing our society downrigs
that no no that's his biology second of
all women will have the testosterone
levels so they don't have the confidence
they have estrogens who are more
connecting so I know you Pro yeah and I
said we haven't had this kind of
discussion but I know you on this just
by being a woman you are you know you're
putting out good stuff and you know that
if it's taken seriously it's gonna make
people's lives better so you want to
connect to everybody so you you will
look at that one bad comment
compared to the 10 amazing ones and
because that's my new nature of a woman
now here's what happens and that's why
here's what happens one of the easiest
ways guys and look at me in the camera
right now one of the easiest ways to win
a woman's heart over and connect with
her is to look her in the eyes and say
honey I Choose You
see because that's so connecting builds
their hormones gives them confidence
does all those great things see if you
look at a man and you look at a man and
Pearl and you say that kind of language
him because remember men and women can't
speak to each other saying and you look
at a man and say honey I Choose You he
looks at you says no kidding I'm amazing
I choose me too
you said but see here's Apple this right
because that's not stimulatory hormones
that way so so what I want you to do is
when you look at those comments one of
those things just understand your
message look at the broader aspect your
message is connecting to a lot of people
but you know some of this I I mean this
sincerely by Nature I don't like
everybody I meet that means everybody's
not going to like me right so therefore
keep doing your work keep those things
but see I'm giving this advice based
knowing that you're a female and having
hormones and advice to the males knowing
their hormones and we have to stop
thinking that we're equal because equal
even by definition means that we're the
same and we can't speak to a man and
speak to a woman I can't speak to my
female employees the same way I speak my
male employees it actually does not work
it doesn't motivate them the same way it
doesn't get them the same way and you're
actually going to end up with a very
unhappy employees
yeah the
that's actually true with um
even in sports like I'll think I'll see
like my coaches coach our team and the
men's team and they coach them
completely different you have to you
have to see that Mary told you the only
acceptable way to be a man today is in
sports in sports see because if you
bring that to the real world you bring
that to the home you bring that to
relationships they're like oh toxic
really those masculine traits are what
you're going like this during the
football game
excuse and yeah it's like but that you
know a good example because you're from
Chicago I'm from Green Bay remember when
Aaron Rodgers did this he did the double
check whether they double it was it
discount double check and he said to
Chicago I own you every female and male
we're going
and every Chicago person is going you
arrogant piece of crap but if that would
happen in Reverse based on the team
you're rooting for did you get my point
but see that masculine trait was awarded
when they're on your team
but when you're not in a team look as
toxic he's arrogant he's just oh in
Chicago his whole career he just said
what was true yeah so
no anyway so same thing I don't and
watch sports so I don't remember do I
know
but wait so no I don't watch horse I
really don't so what okay so I have a
question why does circadian rhythm
matter because like when I think of
different time zones it's like different
isn't it
you don't even like like remember
remember we were talking why and I was
five hours behind
see here's what happens this now think
about this okay the Circadian rhythm
actually is biological it's based on no
joke it's based on you know just
rotation of the earth sun everything
like that and in this is basic science
okay so when you travel back and forth
here's what happens you need to support
your serial rhythms and your body will
adapt to the time zone and your bio
adapt to Nature do you know one of the
easiest ways to help your circadian
rhythm change the minute the sun comes
up no matter where you are take your
shoes off go ground on the earth because
electrons are sitting there waiting for
you which actually changes your biology
you look at the sun it reduces your
melatonin and other hormones and you
start to adapt to the Circadian rhythm
of when the sun comes up and the sun
goes down that's basic it's basic
biology so when I'm white I said I'm in
a pet house in the middle of London
get outside go to the park
kick off your shoes sun comes up look at
the sun lily look at the sun it changes
your biology it really does that's that
every neuroscientists tell you it
changes and gets it brings down your
sleep hormones and talking in general
and brings up your excitatory hormones
get you going through today and so you
so remember I travel I travel a lot for
I have offices all over the world I
travel a lot I speak I ask to go over
there I'm going to come over and come to
your Studio One Day guess what happens
I'm gonna have but I will but you'll see
and then you can even support it
nutritionally I will take some form like
you talk about of some of those herbs
that will actually help me sleep at a
certain time and help me get up that way
just help me adapt but then I don't need
them once I'm adapted I actually I have
another question and maybe a good
hormone explain this I've always felt
like different
I can just like go go and like women
especially like because I can just like
go go go go go go like so much more than
which doesn't make sense because I'm not
I'm it's definitely not my nutrition
right but I I like because my nutrition
is bad I know it's bad you know what I
mean so so it's like I I feel like
like my whole life like people like
don't understand how I can like do so
much at the same time but I like I don't
know why does that make sense absolutely
I I 100 know why 100 okay now think
about this
as an athlete you have trained your body
even if your hormone levels drop you
train your body to
force your body to push out other
hormones that come from your adrenals
because once again those help you deal
with a stressful response as an athlete
you've done this you've had to push
yourself you felt that adrenal loss you
didn't realize there's cortisol and
other hormones that are coming out that
way so you kind of mentally and
physically condition your body to live
that way here's the bad part right
here's the bad part you're 26. you know
what I'm saying you are going to
eventually tank yourself out and then
you're you're gonna go from an extreme
to I could go all time to I can't get
out of bed I see it happen all the time
really now if you to if you learn to
support your body
and do those things you'll be just fine
now once again that's the nutrition
yeah it's nutrition take some medicines
do some things right like I felt it this
like past year or two like I've just
felt it slowing me down and I'm like
what is this I'm like I and I still
think I'm better than like most people
but it's not what like I I could feel it
and I was like oh this stuff's
catching up to me and the other thing is
I feel like relaxing is really hard for
me and I don't know why I'm like it's
like whenever I'm like you oh god let's
do this okay yeah gotta remember let's
go back to the same situation
you've heard the term your adrenaline
junkie okay now what I mean by that is
this is you have been so used to
stimulation from Sports from stuff what
you do for as a career your body's gonna
keep on putting all those hormones it
does but those hormones once again
adrenaline epinephrine norepinephrine
are once again they keep you on edge
they're meant to make your brain go like
crazy so Durham if you were like I said
I've given you some simple Health advice
to help you but if you were actually a
true patient I would actually give you
some things like at seven o'clock at
night and give an example even start
with a little chamomile just start
drinking some chamomile tea at seven
o'clock at night okay you say Doc but
wait it's actually gonna make me not
ready for a show actually believe it or
not it's going to put you in a very
focal state to actually you'll do even
better with your questions and stuff on
your show okay because sometimes you do
this
just start there do we have to do the
medicinal herb don't even spend the
money uh get some good chamomile tea
start doing that and stuff of that and
well do it and what I'm going to do and
like I said I'm just going to show you
the constituents that you can consume
that aren't pharmaceutical because
you're not pharmaceutically deficient
with what you're going through but you
are nutrition now there are certain
deficiencies and oil deficiencies that
don't allow your brain to settle down
but once again you can't keep running on
fight or flight for excessive periods of
time without having some physical or
mental consequence and I'm trying to
protect women even you I'm trying to
protect you by actually making sure we
don't get to that point because you have
a message that needs a continuous spread
and once and ladies you know this once
you get sick you're not a good mom
you're not a good wife you're not a good
worker not all these things but if you
know how to take care of your body you
can continue to form everything you do
it's just that we have no formal Health
Care system with the exception of what I
do instead of that and we've done they
actually can not only support men and
women biologically but also keep them
going
yeah because I went to this like herbal
doctor or something I mean I think he's
similar to what you do but a little
different and he was just saying you're
some of the worst test results I've ever
seen on 26 year old I was like what no
but I work out all the time
well but I've seen your test results
they're not the worst but they're not
normal either there are some problems
there and some of that but once again
can be dealt with so well right now and
that's why I'm trying to tell you know
that's why I get very I get very
frustrated when I hear the saying oh my
daughter's PMS guys that that is it
might be common but it's not normal
daughters PMS like like she's Moody
because she got her period well no if
you look at if you look at the
symptomatology of PMS there could be
changes in blood flow during your cycle
there could be mood changes there could
be cramping there can be blowing there
can be discomfort there can be you know
pain within the uterus or ovaries and
things like that and that's called you
know that's why it's a very common thing
why women are put on young ladies to put
on birth control which is called an end
can disrupt you it's classified as
endocrine disruptor but the idea is this
is those are issues that already show
imbalances that need to be addressed but
because there is well like I said
because our current form of healthcare
system is just going to manipulate your
hormones and it gets her up and do all
bad things it's really sad remember we
talked about I was very proud of you the
other day because remember we were
talking about birth control and then you
did a show on birth control It's like
because birth control changes the
hormones which now change how women view
the world and how they even view guys
and that's been so well documented on
that yeah well
teen and like all my friends are getting
on it
and a lot of kids and I was thinking it
just doesn't seem like that would be
good to have a lot of kids to to shut
off your kids making stuff
yeah and and how it does it is once
again it manipulates inhibits the brain
and other hormonal things man I just
that scares the heck out of me it does
and remember and people say well doc but
my daughter is suffering so they put her
on it well once again she's not
suffering because she's on a birth
control deficiency syndrome now see I
make up terms like that because it's
like it doesn't even sound right no
there's other deficiencies other things
that are going on to help her normalize
that and on top of it you need to find
the stressors that led to some of those
things in the first place so that's why
it's very easy for for us to walk
through with women on these things but
what did it gave me a very Global aspect
of like masculinity femininity all the
things and if they cross what can happen
and that's how once again that's how the
first transgender person came into me
probably 15 years ago and just had some
questions and and I just asked some
questions back I asked one simple
question to him I said do you have
hormone testing done and he said no and
I said as a doc may I test that and he
said yes and his estrogens were elevated
on him
and did it did it fix it like when you
fix his estrogen levels and did he still
want to be a she or whatever so so
here's what happened now here's so
here's what's going to happen and I'm
gonna set this stage and I was waiting
for you to ask me this
you have just like right now no one has
ever experienced what you did as far as
being attacked like you have you've been
attacking some of us has and we can
relate we can empathize okay
so no one can take away my experiences
as a clinician nobody can no one can
take away just because I have a
different background just because I just
because I you know went to undergrads
for different degrees and went to cover
at school went to other schooling that
way my post graduate work all stuff of
that no one could take my clinical
experience away from me so the reason
why I set that up is this I have dealt
with a significant amount of people and
I will just underestimate about a little
over a hundred people that dealt with
transgender for the last 15 years
um now once again clinically here's what
happened the people I took care of I
wasn't trying to focus on their beliefs
and what they were I was focusing on the
hormone levels that could change them
both physically and psychologically
and I have been very blessed to tell you
that when we start to normalize them all
of them start to shift back to the
normal thought process even to the point
where parents came into me and said they
now want to be called by their correct
gender name and stuff and no one could
take that away from me because you know
why I have data on it I actually had
labs done on them I had post Labs with
them getting better and so my whole
thing was my job isn't to judge what you
believe or what you're going through
it's my job as a doctor to get your body
back to normal and the consequence of me
getting back to normal is they had
psychological and physiological change
which would you and I would say being a
normal female and normal male was
okay so yes in the world of so I don't
look at as like I'm trying to fix them
from being transgender that was never my
objective my objective was these people
are have certain hormone imbalances that
can lead them that how they perceive the
world how they perceive themselves what
could end up and that's why if you ever
look
if you ever look at stop just looking at
the psychological aspect these people
also have physical things that are going
on with them but they don't want to talk
about them even though they're directly
related so I've had as as people would
say success at helping them get their
things back to normal and then their
psychological aspect went back to normal
well and it's crazy because a lot of
parents will just like start them on
hormones and stuff and I think that's so
irresponsible
well you know why it's irresponsible so
I'm getting interviewed on a national
show tomorrow because if I were to just
give you this and so anybody that
disagrees with me I'm going to give you
just a simple scientific thing I
actually even have it here on my
computer right here okay now watch this
Pearl you're gonna love this even for
your show okay here's just basic
research you can look this up that guess
what happens
sex is a major determinant of a certain
enzyme in the body to deal with certain
hormones meaning what meaning women have
more enzyme than certain enzyme and I'll
list it for you so your listeners can
try to debunk me on this fact check me
on this cyp3a4
enzyme okay it's part of the whole p450
cytochrome aspect of the body and it's
mainly in liver small intestine and
other organs but here's the point
women by Nature have more of it because
once you have estrogens produced they
need to be converted to other forms so
by Nature women have more so now
they have more genetically so they're
going to produce more because they have
a higher load of estrogens in there now
if we take males and put the same levels
of estrogens in them regards to what
they think they are their body does not
have the the physical capability the
enzymatic capability to convert that
hormone which is going to lead to an
elevated level which is going to lead to
major physical and mental problems
see so I don't want to have discussions
about what you think a male is and all
these things that I'm going to go just
take this one enzyme that is meant to
convert hormones from one form or the
other and women have a dominant in it
compared to men because they have they
have to convert all these things and now
if you take that level of a female and
put into a male you're gonna make them
sick
director you have took an oath to do no
harm and now you're going to harm them
that
the it's like it's kind of back to the
breakdown of the family and it's almost
like we're living worse lives than we
were before but with like better
Technologies what I realize because
there's all these people that grew up in
single parent homes or even me I was
thinking about this where I grew up in a
two-parent home like two parents that
loved me but they're still because I was
so into sports right I mean if I'm if
I'm gone if I have school six seven
hours a day then I'm going to sports
five hours a day what time do I have
you don't even know that yeah and I'm
going away on weekends like travel I
don't know what you know about travel
volleyball but it's like it's very
intense where it's like on um
yeah oh yeah yeah so you know two three
weekends out of the month you might be
out of state right yep and so it's like
I I realized I was like there's some
basic skills that I don't have
because I was so freaking busy in high
school and so like I've been learning to
cook the last two years and I'm a lot
I'm a lot better but I realized I was
like it's like when I when I went on my
own it's like this basic thing and even
me like in high school I'm like it's
like the quality of food was so low it's
like we're living worse than we were
before because we're trying to like do
so much you know and then I realized too
like through people that I know where
like okay that I there's someone that I
know that group in like a single mother
home and I'll call my dad for like
everything or my mom or whoever it is
right and they were they were saying
like oh I'm so jealous that you get to
like call your your dad like I've no I
don't know anyone that calls their dad
and I'm like what you don't and so what
I realized is I was like because of like
the breakdown of the family which I
think is women's fault yeah I think it's
all women's fault but that's a different
but but like we we live like worse lives
than before even though we have better
technology than before because we're
like sleeping worse we're eating worse
we spend less we and we we don't have
extended families we have we don't spend
as much time with our parents you know
we move all over the world and I was
like wow it's it's kind of crazy because
when you look at it from like a macro
perspective it's like we're living worse
lives even though we have more
technology
well let me let me give it and I I
thought at least this I 100 agree with
you but let me spin it a little bit
um the concepts and ideas that I shared
with you today you could be a single
mother and apply these
you really could see I think what
happens is this I agree that the
breakdown of the family has been
absolutely devastating for things but
you gotta remember I take care I took
care and I still do of single moms that
actually apply these things and I can
give you one example of a woman that
actually no joke she was probably the
worst fertility uh um in as far as
physical state I ever took care of and
obviously she has a awesome baby boy
well not a baby anymore uh about three
years old but here's the point is the
fact that she takes all these Concepts
being a single mom now and no joke and
they're honor her husband was abusive
physically so she had to believe it I'm
which I was surprised how much that
happens but the idea is this is and now
she's applying these Concepts to her but
also to her son and she's also saying
Hey listen I can't be that mask in part
two so she's actually had other people
actually be that masculine part to her
so yes it's much easier so here's what
happens it's much easier to accomplish
these things with a two-parent household
but I think what happens this if my
message I gave you went to a single
moment or a single man or a divorced
woman or Doris man that way and they
apply these things and say listen let's
say that all of a sudden my wife died I
will say listen and let's say I want to
stay single okay I would want to have
those feminine assets brought into them
but as a guy here watch this as a dad of
four daughters I have never once asked
my DARS to be masculine not once you say
I'm not once because you know why and
you talk about do you talk about you
know um daughters calling my oldest
daughter who's married my other
daughters and some of that they come to
me constantly that way because you know
why because Endura and I have a
masculine son-in-law be kind of cool and
because he was with me for four years
training like crazy like this to be a
man okay but ideas this so so think this
way because here's what happens here's
where you're going to get criticism I
think even conservatives in in United
States get criticism there is a lot of
people are divorce what do I do now I
failed no no apply the concepts of
masculine and femininity and guess what
happens this do you know how many people
I had a doctor a young female doctor
literally ask me this will you be my dad
and I said yes
see I can step in at masculine role and
that's what we can do as a society see
you don't have to be my biological
daughter to treat you as a daughter got
this I know it sounds funny I kind of
treat my company like I'm that masculine
dad do you say I'm saying and I'm gonna
protect you women from stressing out
even within a thing and thinking of even
a great husband but this whole
environment is going to be that way so I
would rather say people this the
breakdown of the family actually is bad
but you don't say is this I can actually
tell you look at men today men aren't
being taught how to be men women are
taught I'll be women so even if they're
together you just have two bad ideas
together and it doesn't work you know
what else I realized I was like even
like men and women together like there
are very few couples that really
interact with each other like masculine
and feminine like a lot of times it's
not taught yeah no I know and that's the
thing like I realized it started with
like our grant like I feel like our
grandparents generation was like kind of
like the beginning of the end or like
like my like the 40 to 50 year olds like
they're all the ones that are divorced
now and their parents were separated and
their parents stayed together like
that's what I've noticed when I've asked
people I got a parent so they're good
opinions okay go ahead and it relates
what you're saying I got a very good I
got opinion on this I apologize for I
very apologize for interrupting you
um but you you I don't want to lose this
thought if you think about this way and
can you do me a favor can you say hi to
Auntie for me I absolutely love it
she's absent but let's take that concept
do you know something funny I loved your
video the other day when you call it
wife School I love that you see see if
you think this way I there's a
difference between you know raising your
kids and training your kids see if a
parent now this is again this is not
going to go over well
if a parent ever says to you I gave you
a great home okay you had them you're
supposed to give them food and shelter
but if all you do is give your kids food
and shelter then you're gonna let the
world teach them School teach them
churches teach them which I'll don't go
there because I I love Jesus and some of
that but I think churches have done a
horrible job of training and preparing
kids so we are not preparing young men
for the competitive World we're not
training and preparing women for what is
going to come up to the world that way
so they go to college and they go I'm
getting attention and look at all the
girls what they do when they get there
because they weren't prepared saying
listen guys were you know they have
major sexual desire that's why I kind of
laughed like going if you let the world
train them up you're gonna get what you
got now see that's why I love your show
that's why even what I do as a doctor
I'm trying to train up young ladies and
young men to actually be good Society
People based on their biology and I
started out just having sick women we
need to start training why do you think
your show is popular because you're
actually training you don't realize that
bro you're training people for better
future Generations a lot of the men
should be on there just saying Pearl
thank you because you're setting these
women up to succeed vice versa we need
to set the men of 16. well and a lot of
people act like I think I'm perfect with
it and I certainly don't like I think
like like every most I think most people
like like I always say I was sort of
raised to be a boy like I grew up
between two boys and I was just a tomboy
I didn't really care about that stuff
and I just think that in like it was
really interesting to like think about
men and women relationship Dynamics
because I was like oh wow you know
becoming one of the boys doesn't make
you make them want to date you you know
like if anything it's like the opposite
effect
well because you know why but you know
why here's what happens
now I I wonder I want to pull this up
just give me two seconds here I
apologize for this but this will make
complete sense when I bring this up okay
when you look at um your way let me let
me grab this real quick oh I forgot I
did I I do trains at my company on a
regular basis okay
um it's wait what would I call that last
time it was Zoom
um here we go
um when you look at you talked about the
characteristics we considered tomboy
whenever you as a young kid let's say
you had those characteristics of males
competitive and decisive and Laser
focused and all these things they
consider you a tomboy now as a young
girl that's fine okay but see here's
what happens that's not really a tomboy
you just are you just displace those
characteristics but what women forget is
they also have those feminine
characteristics which are which are
needed some women show them more than
they show the Tomboy at quote aspect
that way but here's what happens and
this is why I believe women now watch
this
this will bring women mental peace
Society was built by men it's based on
those characteristics of men and the sad
part is this is and we're trying to get
away from that but that's how you
remember competition creates better
things you're an athlete you understand
creates better quality competence piece
very efficiency
so now women go into the work world
women that succeed in the work world
have to be tomboyish and and kind of
take on those marital characteristics so
therefore that's why you can see succeed
in the business world but here's what
happens this if you try to bring the
femininity into the business world
that's what the wolf culture is trying
to do it's all about atmosphere and
actually culture and stuff of that yeah
but that doesn't pay the bills
that if you actually went to if you went
to an NFL player a Chicago Bear since
you're from Chicago and said you know
something you need to be more
compassionate
account see you laugh about that yeah in
sports it's the only way men could be
men but that's not the real world do you
see him Sam and I look at women say
listen you're so feminine now this is
not gonna get me some fans now you're so
feminine don't enter the workforce
because you know why you're gonna get
crushed and when you get crushed you're
gonna go to HR and try to get HR to make
the people that are competitive making
the company better bringing the money in
you're going to make them less and
you're gonna hurt society and I know
that's not appealing to people but
here's what happens the more feminine
you are and that's this the more
feminine you are you're gonna attract
more of those masculine men because all
the traits that I like are not tomboyish
my investigative journalist Aaron right
here she has loud characteristics that
made her my lead investing a journalist
but her husband also works for me but
when she gets home tonight she knows how
to turn on her femininity so she she
does that so come work for me have some
of those masculine traits but don't
forget you're a woman don't take that
away from you don't transfer that to
home because your husband doesn't want
to be competed with he wants those
feminine qualities and peace and
everything if we so who has it easier in
the workforce men they do because they
can just be themselves all the time
women you enter the workforce you better
have both characteristics be able to
navigate through there otherwise what's
going to happen is this you're gonna
have to turn those off and when you go
home you have to be feminine otherwise
you're going to lose that masculine man
took like a personality to
daddy like I'm like um 75th I think
percentile agreeableness but so I was
like I wonder how that works like how am
I agreeable but I still like sports and
I like to play and compete I was like
that doesn't really make sense to me I
don't even know why
well sure it does it makes complete
sense though because here's what happens
is there's certain there's certain
characteristics about you that are
competitive and want to win but here's
what happens but you also know to win
with a man you can't use those
characteristics you're not gonna you
can't be in competition with your man
see so see what it is is understanding
that these are male characteristics
these are female characteristics and
here's what happens this we don't here
do you understand how many people I've
I've heard say this that when all of a
sudden if a male goes home and tries to
be a second dad and I'm sorry when men
are not supposed to be second moms okay
except I mean second dad men go home and
try to be a second mom you're actually
competing with that mother
and she'll resent you for that let her
be the mom you be the dad she seems and
it's really funny and that's when women
are like you know just he's more of a
mom than I am that way and she'll
actually feel like less of mom from her
husband you saying and vice versa it's
like if uh if if and I know I apologize
because people don't like this term if a
soy boy which is more of a feminine man
enters the Work World he'll be chewed up
because he's not competitive right
and this is and that persist and I mean
sincerely that's why when guys start to
get obese I'm sitting there going man
your testosterone levels are going to
start to drop and you're going to walk
into a a world that's very competitive
and very you know
Society driven that way which is great
because those characteristics build
Society in all the world and you're
gonna try to compete good luck you you
your physical stamina can't even keep I
could work 20 hours a day I can get I
can get six hours sleep every night and
still go I run Utah 100 miles an hour
but guess what I don't eat anything bad
I do the right things for my body my my
testosterone levels are are 851 which
would be considered teenage levels but
that's what we can do wow and I'm 48
years old you're you're inspiring me I'm
coming to start going to bed on time I'm
gonna start thank you I'm gonna start
stopping eating sugar oh my gosh I'm
almost starting at they get here 6 30
now eight we used to start at like 11 30
11. so we're now at eight which is good
for us you know yes
maybe maybe one day we'll get to Seven
you know well I'm very I'm very happy
that I made some simple
uh simple things for you for that can
change your life dramatically that's
what I'm hoping everybody's gonna get
from this podcast away is I know some of
the things I said are going to be
challenging because there's change
that's needed but the change is good and
it can lead to great things both
physically and mentally and that's all
I've done as a doctor for 24 years and I
came out from a different perspective
and because our current perspective is
leading people down the wrong way and so
there's people like you that go out
there and say
I disagree and I wrote a book and no
joke me and Aaron and we wrote a book uh
um again I just said I disagree and my
new book is coming out in September it's
called I still disagree because it does
it's actually gotten worse from what I'm
teaching is the totally opposite it's
gotten worse over the last 24 years but
I won't stop teaching they've they've
they've shut down my YouTube they've
shut down my Facebook they've kicked me
off things but you come back and you
just keep on going because you know why
people will find good messages they're
gonna find them so yep anyways well
thank you thank you so much for coming
on I love listening to you talk like I
learned so much every time I talk to you
actually um do you want to tell the
people where they can find you find your
Channel
um well my whole thing is called The
Wellness Way the wellnessway.com
um my Instagram is probably my biggest
it's one thing I haven't been kicked off
yet it's Dr Patrick Flynn
um but yeah like I said I have a ton of
videos on my website that cover all this
stuff it's at the wellnessway.com or Dr
Patrick Instagram
um don't know how long it'll be before I
get kicked off that but at least my
website they can't kick me off and
everything because I host my own servers
and everything of that so it's kind of
nice but uh you know thank you so much
for having me on I really appreciate I
shared some ideas that uh are going to
change people's lives and make them
better
um maybe maybe when I'm in um
hago maybe I'll come up see your studio
and stuff I'm gonna be there next month
like end of next month
more than welcome you come hang out in
our Studios and so that Sierra our
amazing team Sierra writers see our
doctors see us this and uh our major
corporate office uh is here in Green Bay
Wisconsin okay
[Music]
make sure you
grab to the channel
time
[Music]